attéerant les rues à grande circulation
les cadiaques les hôtels à quatre
étoiles les lieux de plaisir et les
vitrines des magasins en témoigne les
mots d'ordre de l'empereur sont
puissance militaire et industrialisation
accélérée ce fut l'un des destins le
plus prodigieux du siècle ce fils deun
nomade illétré sera sacré roi des rois
il sera la tête de la puissance
militaire la plus importante du Proche
Orient RA palevi monte sur le trône de
l'Iran en
1941 son père racha qui avait pris le
pouvoir à la suite d'un P vient d'être
destitué par les Anglais et les
Soviétiques qui arrivent en Iran en
conquérant réveillant le sentiment
nationaliste du peuple iranien il
parvient à reprendre au Russe une partie
de
l'Azerbaïjan désormais les yeux du monde
seront braqués sur ce pays car l'Iran
est le troisème fournisseur de pétrole
du monde et du point de vue géographique
et stratégique il occupe une position
clé dans le golfe
Persique en 1951 l'autorité du chat
paraît chancelée quand le docteur
mossadek nommé Premier ministre tente
d'arracher le pays à l'influence
occidentale et nationalise le pétrole
mais 2 ans plus tard l'armée du
souverain et la CIA écrase l'opposition
et écarte mossadek son couronnement a
lieu le 26 octobre
son royaume baptisé Iran en 1935 est
grand comme quatre fois la
France terant la capitale est une ville
cosmopolite où la Perse d'hier et l'Iran
d'aujourd'hui marche côte à
côte les Iraniens 30 millions
d'habitants possèdent depuis 1906 une
constitution et un
[Musique]
parlement
atant les rues à grande circulation les
cadiaques les hôtels à 4 étoiles les
lieux de plaisir et les vitrines des
magasins en témoignent les mots d'ordre
de l'empereur sont puissance militaire
et industrialisation accéléré les
premières années 70 se placent sous le
signe de l'euphorie le chat ouvre grand
les robinets du pétrole et le vent cher
en 75 il dispose de 100 milliards de
francs et il espère conduire son pays au
rendez-vous technologique du 21e siècle
c c'est la grande industrialisation
fondée sur l'énergie nucléaire qui
remplacera dans 30 ans le pétrole en
voie d'épuisement constructeur et
banquier le chat voit se presser autour
de lui tous ceux qui ont quelque chose à
vendre ou qui doivent emprunter il
devient un homme de stature
internationale les grands de ce monde
ferment publiquement les yeux sur la
triste réalité qui se cache derrière la
surface clinquante du miracle économique
iranien ainsi que sur les crimes de sa
police secrète la la
savque en
1978 50000 américains travaillent dans
le pays leurs investissements on irant
ce chiffre à 700 millions de dollars
devenu le gendarme du Golf Persique
racha entretient néanmoins des rapports
économiqu important avec l'Union
soviétique ce qui permet aux Russes
d'observer discrètement ce qui se passe
dans cette région du monde que
pensez-vous de l'expression de
despotisme éclairé majesté qui est
parfois employée par certains
commentateurs régime c'est très possible
éclairer je les en remercie
despotismes c'est un peu interprétation
différente qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire
pour gagner le temps perdu ce que moi je
dois faire dans 10 ans contre ce que
vous avez fait en 300 ou 400 années mais
ni les bruits des festivités qui se
déroulent à perspolce ni les effets de
l'industrialisation ne parviennent
jusqu'au villages iraniens ici il n'y a
ni e ni électricité les moyens de
transport n'ont pas changé depuis le
Moyen-âge la population familique et
inconsciente semble vivre comme elle
vivait à l'époque de cyus le il y a 2500
ans stupéfait l'Occident s'aperçoit que
l'islam que l'on croyait un des piliers
du régime en fait cristallisé la colère
populaire il devient de plus en plus
clair surtout à partir de la prise
d'otage de l'ambassade des États-Unis
que la révolution iranienne déclenché
sous la bannière de l'islam est en fait
une révolution sociale devant la vague
d'anti-américanisme qui risque de
s'étendre sur tous les autres pays du
Golfe Persique l'Amérique et les
Occidentaux se demandent pendant combien
de temps ils pourront rester les bras
croisés la colère contre le chat et les
Américains qui couvent depuis longtemps
a précipité la chute de les chat
[Applaudissements]
palev
depuis le début de l'année malgré tout
Majesté les émeutes les manifestations
on été nombreuses avez-vous un moment ou
un autre penser qu'il allait falloir
prendre un virage abrupte éventuellement
démissionner pour arriver à quoi
résoudre le problème mais est-ce que ça
résoudrait le
problème vous savez ce qui se passerait
en Iran non ben réfléchissez un
peu
[Musique]
y